hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're in round
2 of the 2015 sync failed cup probably
just the most ridiculous tournament all
year we have 10 of the best chess
players in the world nine of those are
actually ranked in the top 10 so pretty
crazy today's featured match we have
Fabiana Caruana
in my opinion one of the best
up-and-comers young guy who i think is
going to challenge magnus carlsen in the
future for kind of the best chess player
for many many years to come
he's actually playing under the american
flag for this tournament which is pretty
cool especially since this tournament is
in the United States st. Louis Missouri
his opponent none other than Magnus
Carlsen the current reigning champion so
going to be a really good match what's
interesting about this is both of these
players lost in round 1 fab AR Caruana
Austin Levon Aronian he was playing the
black pieces in that match and then
Magnus Carlsen lost playing the white
pieces in round 1 to top wabun in a
pretty disappointing round one where he
had an advantage let it slip away so
going into round 2 both of these players
looking to get back on track needing a
win to make sure that they are climbing
up that leaderboards and some of these
players are really really going for it
I definitely already have a couple wins
on board so we'll go ahead and get into
it
Fabiana starts out with pawn to e4 25 9
f3 knight c6 Bishop here to b5 getting
into the right Lopez there's a ton of
ways the black can respond to this but
we do see the more few defense with pawn
to a6 Bishop back here to a4 Knight f6
and then Castle on the Kings side now
Magnus Carlsen has a few options from
here he always has the Russian defence
pawn to d6 pretty common he has the open
defense if he wants to go and take here
on e4 just blow up the center of the
board
here's your classical defense the Bishop
to e7 Castle on the King side go from
there
decides to go for kind of the unorthodox
Archangel defense you don't see it super
often pawn to b5 forcing the bishop back
and then Bishop here too
seven just kind of prolonging getting
his other bishop involved into the game
castling on the kingside opting more to
make sure you controls this long square
diagonal here with this Bishop on b7
thinking that okay this is kind of more
important that even the King safety
right now pawn to a d3 a bishop here to
seven getting ready to castle not too
much threats on the black King but
decides to go ahead and Castle Knight
here to c3 Castle on the Kings side and
then pawn to a3 and Fabiano had a
decision he could play a little bit more
graphs aggressive than pawn to a3 could
play at Knight to d5 if he wanted to
Bishop here to e3 all nice development
moves one's a little bit more aggressive
with Knight to d5 really putting his
opponent to the test but as you kind of
saw through this a game it kind of
looked like Fabiano wasn't quite as
prepared for that I Archangel defense
not sure if he just didn't expect Magnus
Carlsen to play that but all in all
Magnus Carlsen was playing much faster
in this game than Fabiana was after
Fabiana plays pawn to a 3 we see pawn to
d6 just completing this pawn chain right
here work over here to e1 and then Queen
to d7 completing the development for
Magnus Carlsen
a knight back here to e 2 it kind of
looked at and said there's no place for
this night to really go here so decides
to go ahead and maneuver it over to the
King side just tried to start an attack
on the King side so Knight to e2 Knight
back here to d8 man is kind of looking
at the same thing it doesn't like any of
his options really so decides to go
ahead and move over to the King side as
well Knight to g3 Knight here to e6 and
then Bishop to a2 this is just kind of a
waiting move it's not really improving
the position too much not really under
any threat right now but just kind of
kicking back here to a2 just saying hey
if anything is gonna happen I'm just
gonna kind of wait and see maybe wasn't
prepared for this opening as much as you
would have liked so this is kind of a
safe move still controlling the same
thing and it can kind of feel - crossing
out to see which direction he wants to
go we're over here - E
a knight up here to g5 a pawn to d5 my
name is Carson has again that pressure
on the light squares in the turn of the
board especially with this net over here
on f6 so putting a lot of pressure
Bishop Knight and Queen right here can
always swing his rook over here to d8
put even more pressure on this important
d5 square right here we see Knight
taking up here on e6 and the Queen's
gonna recapture and then Bishop up here
to g5 pinning that down after pawn to h6
Fabio decides to go ahead and capture
here and give Magnus Carlsen the double
Bishop pair so for the rest the game
managed Crowson is gonna be looking to
kind of open this board up right now
it's kind of clogged with pawns in the
center of the board that's not really
where bishops are going to do really
well bishops are gonna do well win
there's a lot of space they can control
a lot of the board to this bishop right
here it's kind of blocked in with the
pawns so it can move one square forward
this Bishop right here it's not doing
too much at all so that's kind of magnet
Magnus Carlson's plan Caruana on the
other hand he's gonna try to continue to
keep it clogged up it's gonna be
somewhat difficult just because there
can be very easily Magnus Carlsen can
just trade off material right here he's
gonna try to just continue his pressure
as well on the center of the board
so Queen here to f3 adding a nother
defender kind of on this d5 diagonal
right here pawn to c6 doing the same
thing both sides just kind of stacking
up right here pawn to c4 so you can
start to see all the tension in the
center of the board
a rook over here to d8 recognizing this
is where you want your rooks in the
center especially for this particular
game it's all revolving around the
center and one of these sides is going
to come out on top
now Fabiano decides to go ahead and take
on d5 kind of open it up pawn taking
back on a d5 Knight up here to f5 I
really like just rook over here to see
one controlling this long open file
right here but decides to go ahead and
play for a little bit more aggressive
move of Knight to f5 a nice little
outpost for this Knight right now
Bishop here too
a g5 outpost can kind of get aggressive
if he wants to Punta Piedra h4 and then
Bishop to D - so magnus carlsen then a
little frisky trying to get involved
into the action down here on his
opponents side a rook up here - e - now
pawn taking on e4 and after the pawn
captures you can kind of see - Carlson's
playing right here his D rook on the aid
kind of controlling this also protecting
this bishop here on D - so we kind of
thought this through many many moves
ahead so this kind of opened up exactly
what Magnus Carlsen wants start to open
up the board he's controlling these
files with his rooks right now so things
are going pretty well for Magnus Carlsen
in my opinion Queen over here to f6
after the exchange the bishop was
attacking the Queen so want to make sure
that that Queen does not fall pile up
here to g3 just solidifying this pawn
chain right here queen or king over here
- f8 not doing a ton on board but just
kind of a waiting move as well
punt up here to h5 I don't really like
the pawn to h5 very much it allows the
bishop to come back here to g5 just
didn't really have to do it but you know
that's okay then punt up here to a4 a
pawn to b4 I really don't like this from
Magnus Carlsen pawn to b4 this pawn
right here it doesn't really have any
defense and Fabiana decides immediately
just to play pawn to e5 which is what he
should do because if Magnus Carlsen
plays pawn to e5 he has a nice solid
pawn chain right here but after pawn to
a5 it's just gonna be difficult for this
pond to really have any defense now if
he wanted to kind of play a rook here to
d4 he first needs to make sure he gets
this Knight off the board so maybe
Bishop here to c8 and then take the
night here on f5 and then he can get his
rook down here to a d4 but it's still
kind of awkward all in all this pawn is
just kind of sitting there for Fabiana
to take so I definitely don't like that
form from Magnus Carlsen wish you would
have just take him let's sit let's go
back and say okay if he does take but
all of a sudden the bishop comes up here
to c4 but this is this is fine he's
to be okay and material so all in all
didn't like it as much but pawn to b4
pawn up here to a5 King back here to g8
not doing too much with his Kings right
now but bishop here to c4 rook down here
to d7 not gonna be able to stop this
threat rook up here to a4 now
threatening to take the pawn here on
before that is now left undefended King
over here to h8 so Magnus Carlsen using
a lot of his moves to just move his King
back and forth the rook decide to go and
take here on a b4 and then pawn to g6
after the exchange the knight is forced
to move but first we're gonna see the
Queen come over here now after the
bishop comes down here to c6 just
because the rook was attacking with the
Queen as backup here after the bishop to
c6 now we see the knight come back here
to e3 we see the bishop recapture here
on e4 so equalizing a material I think
Fabiano has a much better position on
board this mix move is a pretty tricky
one Fabiana decided to go ahead and play
Bishop here to d5 I think that's a
really inferior move he didn't have much
time on board so that's kind of the
thing as you are analyzing these you you
recognize that Fabiano being one of the
best players in the world can probably
find bishop here to b5 but it's not the
easiest find by any means in this
particular case the pawn takes here on
b5 the rook swings over here taking here
on e4 since it was a discovered attack
once the bishop moved and then the Queen
is kind of threatening right here this
is now a passed pawn that's gonna be
very difficult for black to deal with
the rest of the game I think Magnus
Carlsen is gonna have a tough time
defending this on board if I'll be able
to kind of went for a safer play played
Bishop here to d5 definitely not gonna
lose playing like this but much safer
than if you had a little bit more time
maybe finding that Bishop here to b5
after the bishop takes we see the knight
take here on d5 Queen over here to c6
Knight back here to c3 Queen down here
to f3 so Magnus Carlsen
trying his best to try to find something
on board Queen back here to see to rook
over here to DA just trying to try
something you know double-barreling here
on the D file is always good recover
here to e4 just doubling up on his rooks
as well Magnus Carlsen has a last-ditch
effort with rooks down here to D to see
if Fabiano will make a mistake
unfortunately for Magnus Carlsen that's
exactly what Fabiano does it doesn't
seem like he recognized that the bishop
was here on g5 was running out of time
what's interesting is that after this
next move after 40 moves which is kind
of where we're at right now where this
is move 39 after each player moves to
next move they have another hour
extended so they have two hours for the
first 40 moves and then after moved 40
they get another hour
unfortunately for Fabiano he made a
disastrous play and play drew up taking
on d2 just did not see this bishop here
on g5 I think that that's gotta be the
only way that this makes any sense
after rook down here to d2 there's just
no stopping Magnus Carlsen now can't
take back with this Queen the Bishop's
just going to come down so all-in-all
this is going to be very bad threatening
check right now and then
checkmate so Magnus Carlsen very very
easy victory from here so Fabiano after
he had only a few moves ago kind of the
lead kind of a kind of went down add
Rolla Spath I think kind of a safe
routes but no way he should have lost
that plane a bad move Magnus Carlsen
goes on to take the victory so Magnus
Carlsen first two games I don't really
feel like he's playing as well as he
could for sure I think he squeaked out a
win and around 2 that we just covered so
hopefully he can get back on track I
think it's generous for him to have a
win right now
Fabiano following the first two games
it's gonna be tough for him to defend
his title you know last year he won the
first 7 rounds which is just absurd to
think about and for him to lose the
first two this time it's going to be
very disappointing for him
especially playing magnus carlsen
playing so well but hopefully you guys
in joyed around to to the top players in
the world
two of the youngsters playing so well so
we'll see you guys in the next video and
thanks for watching